What are you thinking about I do what I do because of my dad
He was a hero he gave his life for the pursuit of knowledge
Control getting that over
It's crazy out there there's fires everywhere and plane crashes. They're calling it the search
Major we have some highly classified information. What can you tell us about the Lima project?
Its objective was to search for advanced extraterrestrial life
the ship disappeared approximately 16 years into the mission and the commander was
It was my father Sir
This might come as quite a shock to you
Your father was experimenting with a highly classified material that could threaten our entire solar system
All life would be destroyed. We're counting on you to find out what's happening out there. I
Worry about you. I love you
Please begin your psychological evaluation
As best you can please describe your current mental and emotional state
I am feeling good ready to do my job to the best of my abilities
I remain fully committed to the lawful completion of the mission
If necessary, I will destroy the project in its entirety
The earth was hopes in him
And now it's fake there's no me
We have a job to do are you ready I'm ready